[Music]
so here we are trying to negotiate what
might seem non-negotiable why do these
things feel so non-negotiable one reason
is that we hold certain values and
beliefs as sacred the other side holds
alternative values and beliefs as sacred
and if my beliefs don't match up with
yours we have an impasse we have
gridlock the question is can you get out
of gridlock and how do you get out of
gridlock is it true that you cannot
negotiate the non-negotiable you can the
most powerful tool I know on how to
negotiate the non-negotiable is the
power of appreciation what I mean by
that it is the ability to deeply listen
to the other side's perspective not just
so that you can argue back but so that
they feel heard now this is the hardest
thing to do in the world if you're a
strong Clinton I adore Trump right to
say you know what start by understanding
that other side's perspective you're
going to look at me like you're crazy
and even if you don't think I'm crazy
you're going to try and do it and let me
tell you what I see happen a lot people
try to understand the other side and two
minutes later they say oh no I
understand your perspective but you're
just wrong it's not a two-minute
conversation you know it's at least a
half hour to an hour it's not yeah I get
it it's no I don't get it help me
understand tell me more talk to me
that's the kind of conversation you want
whether it's in the political sphere or
whether it is you know an individual
negotiating with their spouse the moment
to anybody with even the most sacred
beliefs starts to feel heard and valued
their arms are going to uncross they're
going to lean forward and they're going
to say you get it now the danger is they
might then say so why don't you come to
my side yeah but that's okay you've
moved forward they feel heard the next
most important piece then is to say and
just as you have your
perspective I have mine I have my own
sacred values would you be open to
listening to me and to my perspective
you know I understand we are coming from
notice the next word it's not but you're
wrong you know and that's how most of
our conversations take place you look at
the political sphere today I understand
but I was recently talking with the
Congress person he said look I won and I
talked with a whole group of
constituents about this one particular
issue and then and I you know I said I
understand your perspective which was
different than his and after he
explained why he understood all of a
sudden two minutes later he said but and
I said to him boy you've lost that whole
set of constituents right now they don't
feel appreciated you want to say aunt
you know I hear where you are coming
from and I see the value in your
perspective and I'm letting you know
that can start to break through the
walls of the secret once the other side
feels truly heard and understand
understood now they're much more likely
to listen to you and you might start
sharing you might start sharing a little
bit about your own perspective and
instead of saying do you get where I'm
coming from you can say am i mate what
do you hear me saying and simply by
asking that question what do you hear me
saying it forces the other almost to
empathize with your perspective or at
least to try and take that stance of
understanding now success for the other
side is accurately reflecting back what
you said failure is a failure to
actually have listened which allows you
to then correct so what do you think you
know what do you hear me saying I'm not
sure of being clear about why I believe
in this candidate and what they stand
for
what do you hear me say so I think step
one is for each side to truly understand
in a really real way that other side's
perspective and and it's true it's not
just one side understanding the others
each side has to
to understand the others perspective now
this can easily turn into a fire when
one side says you know you crazy or
you're like I can't believe you are my
relative you're my son my daughter Oh
idea boy you know I didn't raise you the
way I wanted to raise you your value
systems are different than the way I
thought they should be you are wrong for
believing what you believe now it's at
that moment in time that's the critical
moment are you going to respond at that
point in time when the other side's
attacking your belief systems by saying
f you know it's your fault
you're wrong or at that point in time
are you going to say you know what help
me understand more that and that might
seem soft and weak it is the toughest
and hardest thing to do you know there
I've worked with hostage negotiators
with crisis negotiators in situations of
war this is what moves things forward
that ability to deeply listen to the
other side even when they're throwing
that toxic energy at you you don't need
to absorb it all you don't need to you
know sort of swallow all that negative
energy my advice just let that negative
energy fly right by you hit the wall
behind you you're listening for the
message you are holding on to the
meaning that they're sharing but you're
not going to let their approach your
adversarial approach to this
conversation dominate the framing of how
you're gonna have a conversation so so
people say listen and and listening is
the hardest thing in the world to do you
know I mean when it comes to emotionally
charged conflict why is it so hard to
listen because my identity is feeling
threatened
you're not just attacking some cerebral
ideas I have you are attacking my value
system my mic mic what I believe
represents the core safety of my family
of myself the meaning I bring to life
and once you attack that oh it's really
hard not to have that snake's head go
and bite off your head another tool that
you can use in a conflict
situation is to ask advice the moment
you find yourself in conflict with the
other side
don't entrench yourself in your position
as my physician what's your position on
healthcare boy that's going to get you
nowhere except toward impasse and
gridlock instead ask what's your advice
you know look you know more about the
other side's perspective than I do I
know more about mine what's your advice
on how we might work most effectively
together what's your advice on some
policies that might address your
interests and you know maybe some of my
constituents interests as well the
moment you ask advice it almost
automatically invites the other person
from that role of adversary into the
role of colleague
[Music]